apple's iphone event just finished and
they finally revealed their brand new
iphone 13 lineup so in this video i'm
gonna go through all of the new features
and benefits of the pro models
specifically compared to the previous
iphone 12 pro models to help you decide
if you should actually make the upgrade
and this year there is a massive change
compared to what apple did with last
year's pro models but before i get into
helping you decide if you should upgrade
or not let's go over all the new
features and specs of apple's brand new
iphone 13 pro first off i want to
mention that both models come in the
same sizes as before with 6.1 and 6.7
inch displays they also both get the
same ceramic shield front glass as
before the same overall design with the
stainless steel chassis the same 128
gigs of base storage the same display
resolution the same ip68 water
resistance the same selfie camera
hardware and the same charging speeds
including 15 watt max safe but now
getting into the differences the most
obvious difference is the smaller notch
which definitely looks better than
before and it's due in part to apple
moving this speaker grille to the top of
the device and interestingly the selfie
camera is now on the left side instead
of on the right on the back of the
iphone 13 pro models the camera bump is
now massive compared to last year and
i'll explain why when i get into the
camera section but i want to quickly ask
you guys to click that subscribe button
and check out our new merch like her m1x
chip shirt down in our merch shelf below
this video the iphone 13 pro models now
also get a new sierra blue color instead
of pacific blue which i honestly am not
a fan of with the rest of the color
options staying unchanged this year the
iphone 13 pro is surprisingly quite a
bit heavier
204 grams instead of 189 on the 12 pro
and the new 13 pro max is 240 grams
instead of 228
so they're definitely heavier this year
they're also a bit thicker
7.65 millimeters instead of the previous
7.4 millimeters on the 12 pro models but
the absolute biggest change this year is
the new pro motion technology which
allows the display to refresh at up to
120 hertz and the best part about it is
that it works automatically and it
dynamically adjusts between 10 hertz and
120
depending on the content that you're
viewing but the very unique feature is
that it adapts in real time so if you're
swiping through photos it'll speed up to
a higher refresh rate and then slow back
down to 10 hertz if you're looking at a
still image for just a split second this
by itself will greatly help save battery
life on the new iphones and it's why the
13 pro gets 1.5 hours more battery life
than the 12 pro and the new max model
gets 2.5 hours more than the 12 pro max
however i do want to highlight a very
interesting tidbit and that's the fact
that if you look at apple's rating for
the streamed video playback battery life
which includes watching youtube videos
the 13 pro gets up to 20 hours instead
of just 11 on the 12 pro and the 13 pro
max gets up to 25 hours instead of 12 on
the 12 pro max which is going to be a
huge deal for those who watch a lot of
videos another cool difference is that
the 13 pro models have a brighter
display that can go up to a thousand
nits in any situation instead of the
previous 800 on the 12 pro models and of
course the iphone 13 pro now gets the
new a15 bionic chip with a few
improvements that i want to discuss even
though the cpu core layout is the same
with two high performance cores and four
efficiency cores the overall transistor
count is going up to an almost 15
billion compared to 11.8 billion on the
a14 but the biggest change this year is
that the gpu on the 13 pro now gets 5
cores instead of 4 on the a14 which
should lead to a pretty huge difference
in graphics performance and if you're
interested in seeing just how big of a
difference there is we're gonna be doing
a direct comparison between the two so
definitely subscribe if you haven't
already now moving on the 16 core neural
engine can now run 15.8
trillion operations per second compared
to just 11 on the a14 and there are even
more upgrades like a new display engine
that will be more efficient new video
encoders and decoders which will help
with video editing and video streaming
double the system cache which will
improve overall performance and a new
image signal processor that improves the
overall camera quality on top of that
apple also mentioned that it has wider
glossy compression support which
basically helps make your photos videos
and audio files use less storage space
than before now before i get into the
massive camera differences i want to
list off a couple of other upgrades
compared to last year first up the
iphone 13 now supports dual e sim which
means that you can have two cell phone
lines without using a physical sim card
at all apple also mentioned that it now
supports more 5g bands which likely
points to a new qualcomm x60 modem that
was previously rumored which will also
improve battery life due to better
efficiency and if you really want to you
can now finally get a one terabyte
storage model if you're willing to pay
the crazy expensive price and now with
all of that out of the way let's get
right into the camera changes and this
is where it gets crazy because unlike
last year the cameras on both the 13 pro
and the pro max are literally identical
in fact the only differences between the
two are literally the display size the
display resolution and the battery life
that's it so with that said both iphone
13 pro models now get a new three times
optical zoom telephoto lens compared to
a 2.5 x zoom on the 12 pro max and just
a 2x zoom on the 12 pro so zoom shots
are gonna be much improved on the new
pro models the only downside is that
because of the new 3x optical zoom the
lens aperture is now f 2.8 instead of as
fast as f 2.0 on the 12 pro model which
means that the lens takes in literally
50 percent less light which is gonna add
more noise to your photos and if you
want to see just how big of a difference
that's going to make we're going to be
comparing the cameras on the 13 pro the
12 pro and the 11 pro very soon now to
combat the slower f 2.8 lens apple is
now allowing night mode to work directly
on the telephoto lens which is a very
good sign now getting into the main wide
camera this is getting a pretty massive
improvement with a new larger sensor
with much larger 1.9 micron pixels
compared to 1.4 on the 12 pro and 1.7 on
the 12 pro max and in combination with a
faster f 1.5 aperture lens there is now
a 2.2 x improvement in low light when
compared to the 12 pro so this is going
to help reduce as much noise as possible
for super clean photos as well as
helping to make night mode shots take
less time than before probably just one
second or less but the camera i'm most
excited for is the new ultra wide camera
because it's getting a major improvement
with a new f 1.8 aperture lens which
almost doubles the amount of light that
goes into the sensor and because of that
apple had to give it a new six element
lens to enable auto focus because the
faster aperture makes the depth of field
tighter and this also helps the lens
focus super close as close as two
centimeters away from a subject to
enable the new macro photography feature
which is going to be incredibly useful
for creative photos and on top of that
apple is updating the 13 lineup to
support smart hdr4 which should give us
another improvement in terms of dynamic
range apple is also adding the new
photographic styles feature which
basically adds a smart filter that can
do things like add more contrast to
photos or make them more bright and
vibrant but the really awesome detail is
that you can adjust the tone and the
warmth to exactly how you like it and
those custom settings will stick
basically forever without having to
adjust them every time so for example if
you think iphone photos are too warm you
can turn down the warmth and voila you
get more cool toned photos and now to
finish off with the craziest new feature
coming to the iphone 13 lineup we have
the new cinematic video recording mode
this feature is going to be
revolutionary and automatically blur the
background as you're recording a subject
and while it's doing that it can detect
multiple faces in the frame so if your
subject turns away it'll automatically
rack focus on the face in the background
and then focus back to the subject again
or you can simply tap on a face to make
it adjust focus and then tap again to
make it track the face as it moves
closer or further away but the absolute
mind-blowing feature is that all of the
depth data is saved on your phone so you
can go into the video and adjust the
aperture or background blur in post and
even crazier you can actually change the
focus point as you're editing the clip
in post if you accidentally messed it up
while shooting and for all of you
filmmakers out there later this fall
you'll be able to record in the pro res
video format thanks to the new prores
hardware accelerators built into the a15
channel and there you guys go those are
all the major differences between the
iphone 13 pro and the 12 pro so let's
finally answer the original question
should you upgrade if you already own
the 12 pro well if you're perfectly
happy with your iphone including how
much battery life you're getting and you
don't mind the larger notch and you're
perfectly happy with the camera quality
then i'd honestly say that you should
just stick to the 12 pro but if you've
been waiting for 120hz refresh rate for
years i think you should upgrade because
it makes the entire phone feel so much
more smooth and snappy than before or if
you would really love the extra battery
life especially the extra 2.5 hours on
the 13 pro max or maybe the over double
video streaming hours then it might
actually be worth it for you or if you
want to have the absolute best camera
quality you can get in any iphone then i
would definitely upgrade those three
features alone are why i'm personally
upgrading to the iphone 13 pro max
especially since i absolutely love the
new look of the massive camera bump on
the back as well as the updated smaller
notch on the front but if those three
features don't really matter that much
to you then i would honestly just wait
it out for the iphone 14 pro because
that model might be getting a full
redesign so hopefully this video helps
you make a decision
and if it did go ahead and click the
subscribe button above and definitely
check out our new merch down in the
merch show below thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]
you